maire qui annonce officiellement sa
candidature un maire qui se présente
pour la deuxième fois aux municipales un
maire qui réaffirme son attachement à la
mairie de sainte luce et plus largement
aux lucéens une opération séduction donc
du maire de sainte-luce nicaise monrose
qui commence par une explication de la
couleur dominante de sa campagne
puis vient l'heure du bilan la carte
atout que nicaise moore aux joues en
premier réorganisation de la mairie
bilan financier positif redynamisation
de la commune en clair le candidat avait
arboré plus que tous les tics est
citoyenne qui l'a adoptée depuis 2014
d'habitude politique et nous nous
posions une action citoyens nous avons
bien géré les affaires de la commune
le budget de la commune nous avons
montré notre dynamisme nous avons
démontré que nous pouvions mais tu sais
plus dans dans une nouvelle ère et nous
proposons à la population de continuer
et le candidat n'a pas hésité à
souligner les divergences existantes
avec la présidence de l'espace sud
il a aussi réaffirmé son opposition à la
construction d'un centre commercial sur
le territoire de la commune notre valeur
ajoutée alors
plus à se situer à l'existant nicaise
monrose l'adjoint qui en 2014 avait
défié le maire de l'époque et qui avait
remporté les élections avec une
importante majorité repart dans une
course aux municipales plus confiant que
jamais